♪ Hey girl ♪
♪ I know you've been with a lot of guys ♪
♪ And it felt like something's missing ♪
♪ 80% of the time,
statistically speaking ♪
♪ But I got a little more
than you're used to ♪
♪ Something I've been
keeping under wraps ♪
♪ Cos I'm the whole package baby ♪
♪ And that's just the tip of the iceberg ♪
♪ Saturday night, hopping out the uber ♪
♪ Got my charm, good looks,
and a sense of humor ♪
♪ Black button up shirt;
splash of cologne ♪
♪ Clubs packed, DJ's
spinning Post Malone ♪
♪ See a hunny by the bar
in a skintight dress ♪
♪ Throw a couple of shapes
and she seems impressed ♪
♪ Touch her arm just a little;
can I buy you a drink ♪
♪ Make eye contact as our glasses clink ♪
♪ She's playing with her hair,
and she laughs at my jokes ♪
♪ So I order us another
two bacardi and cokes ♪
♪ Now her hand's on my knee
and she's stroking my thigh ♪
♪ She says she's never
been with a British guy ♪
♪ It's the moment that I fear,
don't know how she'll react ♪
♪ Compared to other boys
I'm a little more intact ♪
♪ So I whisper in her
ear, don't be surprised ♪
♪ But I'm 100% uncircumcised ♪
♪ Foreskin ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin ♪
♪ Just a heads up baby, it's a warning ♪
♪ I wanna make sure 'cause
I've been burned before ♪
♪ When I show them my foreskin
they show me the door ♪
♪ Girl, I hope you got an open mind ♪
♪ Cos my dick's just like god designed ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin
girl lemme be blunt ♪
♪ There'll be a little
bit more going into your ♪
♪ Continuing on, in the hunt for a lady ♪
♪ Who will make my shaft
stand up like slim shady ♪
♪ Head home with a hottie
from the discotheque ♪
♪ Feel lucky cos she's
wearing a turtleneck ♪
♪ Start fumbling before
we're even in my condo ♪
♪ Hope she doesn't mind that
my dong's wearing a poncho ♪
♪ So I tell her before
we get hot and heavy ♪
♪ I'm hooded like a monk in a monastery ♪
♪ She doesn't understand,
but I soldier on ♪
♪ When we fuck girl, I
don't need lotion on ♪
♪ My natural state has been preserved ♪
♪ Cock like a featherless baby bird ♪
♪ So once the love train has disembarked ♪
♪ You're gonna come face to
face with a pink aardvark ♪
♪ What I'm saying girl,
don't be traumatized ♪
♪ I'm 100% uncircumcised ♪
♪ Foreskin ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin ♪
♪ It's kinda like my
prick's got an awning ♪
♪ I know a lotta Jewish
guys get the snip ♪
♪ Tell the rabbi thanks
guy you can keep the tip ♪
♪ I just tell it how it
is, no need to debate ♪
♪ And I know that I'm at
a higher risk for AIDS ♪
♪ Got a foreskin, flapping
like a kite in the breeze ♪
♪ And I frequently clean
it so there's never any ♪
♪ Cheesy smiles on my wedding day ♪
♪ And I won't let this one get away ♪
♪ Every other girl left, I was so afraid ♪
♪ That we never had sex, I said I'd wait ♪
♪ So we stand in the chapel,
in front of the priest ♪
♪ And I lean in trying to be discreet ♪
♪ And right at the moment
I should say I do ♪
♪ I'm like babe there's a
secret I must tell you ♪
♪ Suddenly a scream, we all turn round ♪
♪ Outside there's a
building burning down ♪
♪ I push through the
crowd as the fire roars ♪
♪ There's a woman at a window
on the very top floor ♪
♪ Crying and screaming like a crazy lady ♪
♪ Shouting out, somebody
please save my baby ♪
♪ I'll catch him, I replied ♪
♪ I'm 100% uncircumcised ♪
♪ Foreskin ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin ♪
♪ So I stretched it out
and then caught him ♪
♪ The most marvelous sight
that you've ever seen ♪
♪ Turned my pork and
beans into a trampoline ♪
♪ Everybody cheers, I'm the hero ♪
♪ The men told me they
wished theirs could regrow ♪
♪ Thanks to my foreskin,
the child survived ♪
♪ Though sadly the
woman in the fire died ♪
♪ Foreskin ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin ♪
♪ So soft that the kid starts snoring ♪
♪ Foreskin ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin ♪
♪ And now I've gotta raise this orphan ♪
♪ Foreskin ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin ♪
♪ In a few months he'll start crawling ♪
♪ Foreskin ♪
♪ I've got a foreskin ♪
♪ He's a Jew, that's a fact I'm ignoring ♪